- You don't buy a De Lorean
unless you want attention.
Like, you do want to be out
in a De Lorean if you're
having a bad day because
everybody's honking at you
and giving you thumbs up.
It's almost like a happiness mobile.
Even with like 20 other
De Loreans parked around,
like, what is the story with this one?
(upbeat music)
(beeps)
First time I saw a De Lorean
was in a science museum,
I wanna say in 1983, and they
had a brand new De Lorean,
the car of the future parked
in the lobby of the science
museum, it became my dream
car and I always wanted
to own one, but it always
seemed like wanting to own,
you know, Magnum PI's Ferrari,
or the van from the A Team,
like something impossible
that would never happen.
I wrote this novel, Ready
Player One, the protagonist
is kind of obsessed with ‘80s
pop culture, and he loves
Doc Brown's time machine,
but, he decides to take
Doc Brown's time machine
and then mash in three more
of his favorite 80s super
vehicles, the Ghostbuster's
ectomobile, Ecto 1, KITT
from Knight Rider and then
Buckaroo Bansai's jet car.
So it has both a flux capacitor
for traveling through time
and an oscillation over
thruster for traveling
through solid matter.
(upbeat music)
I never imagined that I
would finish the book or that
I would be able to sell it or
that it would become a movie
but all those things happened,
and once I sold the movie
rights then I realized I
could actually buy a De Lorean
finally and then recreate
the De Lorean from the book.
It makes me a lot more
interesting at my book signings
when I pull up in a time
machine, it's like a traveling
‘80s museum.
This is my iPad that I use
to control my time circuits.
This operates the flux
capacitor, but mostly it's just
fun like at the stoplight,
I just pretend that I'm
dropping oil like Spy Hunter,
and then I also have KITT.
- [KITT] A little consideration
would be a beginning.
- And my light bar.
When I need to clear traffic,
because I need to get to,
you know, the site of a
job and bust a class five
full roaming vapor, I can't
be sitting in traffic.
(upbeat music)
I love people who love the
things they love so passionately
that it's just not enough
for them to talk about it,
it has to manifest itself
in their lives in some way.
They have to build their own
time machine or they have
to cosplay, you know, their favorite character.
I'm that kind of person, and
so the car is a way for me
to do that.
(upbeat music)